so the Church of what's happening now
officially ended around 3 years ago in
the time that followed we saw Joey move
back to New Jersey and start Uncle
Joey's joint which is a new podcast for
him that you were featured on a few
times as a guest but besides those
appearances what were you up to during
that time post Church post church was a
fun nerve-wracking time I moved back uh
I spent a couple months in Milwaukee
working on something that didn't pan out
I've been in Massachusetts I lost a good
amount of weight I put a little bit back
on recently like knock on would not all
of it or nearly all of it but I put a
little bit back on and then I've been
working a day job and and working on
Comedy just trying to do and and get as
good as I can